my name is Jack Marchetti I'm a
writer-director and I'm here to talk to
you about the camera I chose to use on
my last film which was also my first
film the evolution of hnx music
purchaser the camera we shot on was a
red epic we shot in 5k and we used red
pro prime lenses I will preface my
remarks right now by saying that if you
know a lot about lenses a lot about
cameras if you're like a camera hobbyist
and you know a ton about them and things
along those lines this is not the video
for you this is more for people like
myself from 2 years ago who you know
first time director hadn't really been
on a set before never really messed
around with cameras and didn't really
know a thing or two about the difference
between a red or an Alexa or what what
you can do with the DSLR even shooting
on an iPhone or aspect ratios and things
along those lines so like I said we
decided to shoot with a red epic one of
the reasons why I wanted to shoot on a
red epic was I had heard about it I knew
that David Fincher used them I like the
look of David Fincher films and so I
wanted my film to look like a movie we
all talk about the film look and what
that is and I just thought you know you
need the camera to do that and it turns
out it's not really the camera that
determines the film looking it helps but
it's about frame selection it's about
the lenses it's about the story and if
you properly frame something in your
iPhone it's gonna look like a movie I
kind of want to talk to you about the
benefits of shooting on a red epic like
I said we shot 5k which is a huge amount
of resolution it's massive and the big
benefit of doing that that I found was
we were able to reframe some shots in
post-production I don't recommend doing
this you should frame correctly on set
you should have your shot list all set
out which we did however when we got
into posts there were a few shots that
we just ran out of time on when you look
back at them
you know a month later they just didn't
look right this shot here we were
running out of time
this was our last night of shooting I
think we had about ten minutes left and
this was the last thing we did and we
set up the camera in the rear window
passenger side window and shot this and
it's it's a very simple thing however
this right here is the exact same shot
we're just punched in about 200% so this
is the actual thing we shot which is
fine but I wanted to punch in a little
bit on him for a close-up and there's
the close-up it's the exact same shot
it's just done in post-production if you
were to do this correctly on set with
the proper lenses the background
probably would have looked a little bit
differently but at the end of the day
like I said who cares we did this again
this shot right here so this is where
this is the altered read this is the
reframe shot this right here is the what
we actually shot this is us punched in
and we're punched in I think maybe a
hundred two hundred percent while still
maintaining 1080p we also did this
similar approach on this shot now I'll
admit right now that this is just poorly
framed I don't actually have an example
of the wide shot that we started from in
the film if we were planning on shooting
it like this we would have probably
changed it though the camera angle
changed the lenses and it would have
looked a lot differently but again in
post you you know when we shooting at
such high res you're really able to mess
around with things like that
another thing that that's a benefit that
you can't get on let's say view shot on
an iPhone or something like that if you
were going that low-tech you're not
gonna be able to get something like this
does see how the background is all out
of focus it's called a shallow depth of
field and you need a longer lens to pull
this off
and so another benefit that I don't
really have a before-and-after to show
you but when you shoot such high
resolution you are
able to if you have a color is not bored
they have almost an unlimited ability to
manipulate the image that you've created
because you've provided them with so
much detail each frame of a red epic is
the equivalent of shooting I think like
a fourteen point four megapixel still
shot so even an enormous amount of data
to manipulate and work with so I didn't
really find anything negative about
working with a red I had heard that
they're very loud and we were shooting
in some places that were actually open
for business like a record store and I
was really worried about this thing
sounding like a hairdryer but it
actually you know I didn't really have
any we didn't have any problems with
that at all one thing we did run into
was we wanted to use a movie stabilizer
however there's a weight limit on that
and our red with the red pro prime
lenses would have exceeded the weight
limit so we weren't able to use the movi
if I could go back two years to when we
shot the film I would probably tell my
more inexperienced self to not get hung
up on the camera I got really set on we
needed to use a pro grade camera
professional prama and I hammered that
point home but then you get into editing
and you realize that you know maybe
you're missing story or maybe the sound
didn't work out or whatever you're not
at all worried about what camera used or
things along those lines at least I
wasn't when we were in the editing Bay
and putting everything together the last
thing I was worried about was the camera
I was more worried about like did we did
we get enough coverage of certain scenes
which we didn't did the story make sense
we had professional sound on set so the
sound was great and I would say if you
if you're putting your budget together
and you have money for sound or money
for the camera shoot on your iPhone and
pay someone to record sound the sound is
going to make your film if your movie
looks like what sounds great people
are gonna assume it looks like
because you wanted it to look like
as an aesthetic reason if it looks
amazing and sounds terrible
people are just gonna assume you suck
and you have no idea what you're doing
and no one's gonna think oh that was
shot on a red epic or an Alexa look at
those skin tones no one's gonna give a
they just aren't and so in
conclusion I would definitely use a rat
epic again I'd have no problem with it
again I would just say that I would not
get hung up on the camera on my next
project if my DP says look let's shoot
on an iPhone let's shoot on a 5d or a 7d
or whatever let's shoot on an Alexa I
don't really care anymore because to me
the camera doesn't really matter and if
I were to leave you with anything and
hopefully you come away with anything
from this just realize the camera really
doesn't matter does it do they have
benefits absolutely but if you frame
correctly like correctly you still
delight correctly and have it sound well
the camera will be the absolute least of
your